this is an interesting case that i just
saw right before we went on air here the
new york times it says two women filed
lawsuits in on wednesday in california
alleging that george foreman who's the
former world heavyweight boxing champion
sexually abused them when they were
teenagers in california in the 1970s
according to the lawsuit the women using
their pseudonyms gwen h and denise s to
protect their identities initially met
foreman when they were under 10 years
old through their fathers one man was a
boxer sparring partner of foreman while
the other was a boxing manager and long
time adviser to form it
foreman then groomed the girls for
several years according to the
complaints before forcing them to have
sex with him in places ranging from a
san francisco health hotel to an
apartment in beverly hills the two women
who are both in their early 60s now
filed the complaints in los angeles the
los angeles county superior court
representatives for foreman referred
inquiries about the lawsuits to a
statement that he released last month
and he says that this that they're
trying to extort him they've been trying
to extort him for years this is a false
claim and he denies it
now you read this story and you think
are there
of course i i don't know if this
happened or not
um
these are claims dating back 50 years
and so you read that and you think are
there no statute of limitations here how
can you come out 50 years later
now if something did happen to you
when you were much younger when you were
a kid it's it's understandable
that kids who are victimized don't don't
oftentimes don't want to come out right
away because they're
they're they're afraid they've been
intimidated that's part of the
conditioning and the grooming but
like once you get to it adulthood at a
certain point you have to say if you if
you wait even not just waiting 50 years
you've waited like 40 years into
adulthood
and now you're saying something at a
time when it's just impossible to prove
one way or another it would be
impossible to do it's also impossible to
if you've been you know if you're if the
claim is false and you're being falsely
accused it's impossible to vindicate
yourself it's just just a claim
so how can you wait 50 years
should there not be some kind of statute
of limitations putting some urgency on
this saying
if you've been victimized we absolutely
want you to come forward but you can't
wait half a century to come forward
because there's nothing we can do with
the claim at that point
well you would think that but actually
california changed their law
relatively recently they changed it in
response to the metoo hysteria and um
according to the law that went into
effect back in 2020
um they extended the statute of
limitations they extended it broadly
just across the board
but then they also basically extended it
indefinitely because now according to
their law
you have
you have to come forward within five
years
if you're if you're claiming you're a
victim you have to come forward within
five years of discovering an injury
so that's the way they've
phrased it in the law
which if you don't think much about it
it sounds like okay well five years
that's okay that's that's not that long
that seems fair
well but they're including psychological
industry uh injury rather so
five years of discovering a
psychological injury
which is another way of saying that you
have forever there is no statute of
limitations
because yeah you could walk into a
psychiatrist's office when you're
65 and say i'm traumatized by something
that happened 50 years ago and that's it
that's all you have to do and now you've
got five years from that first meeting
with a psychiatrist to file a claim
um and it should come as no surprise by
the way that
as soon as california put this uh law on
the books or rather it's amending what
you know the currently existing law as
soon as they amended the law there was
there's just been a rush of claims like
this from people alleging that they were
victimized decades prior
um it's just
obviously total madness
uh
you know you ca it's it there's not an
exact science here as what of what the
statute of limitations should be but i
think any thinking person any rational
person
would agree that 50 years is just way
too long
maybe you know maybe like five years
into adulthood
i think that might make sense
just
you know something between five and
fifty
well if you enjoyed that video be sure
to hit the subscribe button and ring the
bell to get more content like it if
you're craving more content go watch or
listen to my full show at dailywire.com
spotify or wherever you get your podcast